good morning John the star that you saw
in last video was in fact not a star was
Jupiter could tell there's a planet 1
because it is so bright and 2 because
planets do not twinkle the way that
stars do this is because planets are
much closer to us so instead of seeing
just a point of light like we do with
stars we actually see lots of points of
light and a tiny tiny little dis I'm
moving different layers of different
densities of our atmosphere cause the
light from the single point source to
jiggle and the light from the little
disks jiggle as well but all the
different points tend to average each
other out so planets appear much more
constant in their brightness so twinkle
twinkle little star stars don't actually
twinkle they are also very constant in
their brightness our atmosphere just
makes it look like they're twinkling
another lie we tell to children like The
Tortoise and the hare
that's just know I don't care how much
the hare messes around the hares gonna
win hares top speed is like 45 miles per
hour I'm steady doesn't win the race
John you know it wins the race
fast and steady almost exclusively so it
occurs to me having said this that hares
actually have very short lifespans and
tortoises live for like ever so maybe if
the race is the amount of distance an
animal can cover in its lifetime maybe
then maybe a tortoise could win gonna do
the math okay we're back know the oldest
tortoise in the world is named Jonathan
and he is 182 years old this top speed
is point one seven miles per hour
meaning if he traveled every hour of his
life and there have been more than 1.5
million of them he would have by now
traveled about 270 1,000 miles at 45
miles per hour hare would only need 13
percent of its five-year life span to
eclipse the tortoise so yeah hair versus
Jonathan and our really terrible
hypothetical in which neither of them
ever sleep or rest the hare still wins
so the hare has been dead for a hundred
and seventy seven years so maybe the
real moral of the story is slow and
steady loses the race but who cares as
long as you're not dead thanks to
Jonathan the oldest tortoise and also
the oldest Jon for teaching us that one
come on Jon you tell a history of John's
and you forget the oldest Jon every
slacking his arm say here's another
interesting bit of John trivia there
might be more forms of John than there
are forms of any other name Jane Gianni
Juan Ivan Janice Joan
Ian Yanni yeah Yanni these are just a
few outs of them start with that J noise
G but if you say it J noise without
messing with the air as it's coming out
of your mouth it's just a Y noise so you
have
John and then you have yeah and why
noises are weird because they are never
consonant yet another lie that we tell
to children why noises are two vowel
sounds jump together really quick like
with your you don't get to a consonant
until you get to the are it's just II or
your your your your your your that means
our like this do when you say Wednesday
you there's no consonant you say o ends
day it's just vowel to vowel sounds
there so have together you get one of
the coolest words in the English
language the diphthong diphthongs are
everywhere we're pretty bad at hearing
them but even so boards like mic it's my
eek I you see it written down sometimes
like oil
oh I L and we put a diphthong in the
place of a consonant as breaking two
syllables apart basically is acting like
a consonant but it's not a consonant so
we call it a semi vowel in fact in the
name that John came from Johannes it's
actually all spelled out there for
everybody to see all the vowels it also
shows the origin of the silent H because
John basically used to be Johan al for a
piece of seemingly random information
middle English used the suffix kin to
put on the end of words that meant it
was a small thing like if there was a
kid named Tom you would call him Tom Ken
or a small piece of cloth would be
called a cloth skin except their word
for cloth was naps it would be a nap in
the middle english shortened johann
tahan and when there was a little person
named han they would call him honkin
which i am not even kidding
it's how the name hank first appeared
John you and I have the same name I'll
see you on Monday